Минуло п'ять з половиною років, президент Порошенко програв вибори.
В Україні новий президент. Володимир Зеленський.
Це перемога Майдану?
Ну, Майдан стояв за що?
Перша, так би мовити, вимога Майдану була прибрати Януковича,
тобто ми її виконали. Решта вимог не виконані,
а якщо виконані, то не повністю.
Тобто ми хотіли чесні вибори - це в принципі вже майже досягнуто,
бо на останніх виборах всі визнали - і переможені, і незалежні спостерігачі,
що вибори пройшли чесно.
Порушення були дуже незначні і жодним чином не вплинули на результат.
Це заслуга, тобто це вже в принципі теж плюс, теж перемога.
Бо раніше такого не було в Україні, а в Росії досі немає.
Тобто це в принципі перемога.
Якщо є чесні вибори, це вже дуже багато значить.
Потім були вимоги - чесні суди, чесна міліція.
У цьому плані поліція зробила певні реформи,
але систему до кінця переламати не вдалося,
тобто багато залишилося від старого, на жаль.
Сказати, що суди стали чесними, теж до кінця неможливо.
Тобто стало вже краще, ніж раніше, але не так, як хотілося б.
Тому, як я написав у себе в Фейсбуці через тиждень після звільнення,
перший у мене був такий висновок від того, що я побачив:
змін не так багато і не такі разючі,
як я хотів би побачити, як я очікував.
Тобто за п'ять років можна було зробити більше.
Зроблено зміни, але не такі глибокі, як мені хотілося б.
Які у Вас плани?
Плани у мене глобальні, бо я бачу перед собою дві великі мети,
яких я хочу досягнути.
Перша: я хочу, щоб моя країна була цивілізована,
схожа на європейську країну.
Яка живе за європейськими, як то кажуть, стандартами і цінностями.
Щоб вона була незалежна, зокрема і від впливу Росії.
Це дуже важливо, бо поки Росія від нас не відчепиться,
нам буде дуже важко.
У нас є внутрішні проблеми, грубо кажучи,
ще не проведені усі реформи,
країна недостатньо чітко і прозоро працює.
І є зовнішня агресія Путіна.
А також є полонені, які сидять.
І я знаю, що таке сидіти в тюрмі,
і я використовую свої можливості, свій голос, авторитет, який маю,
аби допомогти їм звільнитися.
Сьогодні я у Німеччині, два дні,
і більша частина зустрічей була цьому присвячена.
Я радий, що ті німецькі політики, з якими я бачився,
дуже добре розуміють, хто такий Путін,
як допомогти Україні, і що нашим звільненням все не закінчується.
І повернення Росії в ПАРЄ, мирні спроби переговорів -
це все ще нічого не значить,
Путін Україну не залишить у спокої.
Ви в одному з виступів сказали, що хотіли б бачити
Путіна на лаві підсудних у Гаазі.
Це реально чи це так в запалі емоцій?
Ну, ви знаєте, є такі речі... Я ніколи не піддаюсь емоціям.
Особливо коли виступаю публічно. Я вмію себе контролювати.
Це абсолютно моє, скажімо так не бажання, а маленька мрія.
Бо це було б справедливо.
Покарати його за злочини проти України,
проти самої Росії, проти Молдови, проти Грузії
проти громадян Європи, за збитий "Боїнг" треба відповісти, і це однозначно.
Він не віддав прямий наказ, але це наслідок його дій,
його системи, що його було збито.
І загинули 13 тисяч громадян у війні на Донбасі.
Я хотів би, щоб він відповів за це в суді в Гаазі.
Щоб цей суд відбувся, там необхідний один свідок.
І цього свідка обміняли на вас.
Ні, повірте мені, якби Цемах щось знав, ніхто б його не віддав.
Якби Цемах хоча б щось знав про збитий "Боїнг",
хоч щось, хоч трохи, хоч щось поряд бачив,
його усунули б уже дуже давно.
Бо Україна готується нападати на Росію в суді. Атакувати.
20 березня 2020 року почнеться засідання щодо збитого "Боїнга",
і Росія це засідання програє однозначно.
Тому Росія готується захищатися.
Усі свідки, які хоч щось знали і щось могли сказати,
давно зачищені, їх немає серед живих.
Можете не сумніватися. Серед живих нікого не знайдуть.
Якби Цемах щось знав, його б знищили.
Вони очільника ДНР Захарченка підірвали серед білого дня.
Що їм якийсь Цемах, про якого ніхто не знав і не чув?
Тож це все балачки про те, що мене за Цемаха віддали.
Ні, і Путіну він не потрібний. І нам він не потрібний був, Україні.
Ви збираєтеся йти в політику?
Ні, поки ні.
- А чим будете займатися?
- Громадською діяльністю і кіно.
А громадська діяльність чим є, якщо вона не в політиці?
Те, що я роблю зараз. Чому? У політиці треба бути членом якоїсь партії,
у політиці треба робити певні речі, вибиратися кудись,
обіцяти те, що не збираєшся виконувати, і посміхатися.
А я збираюся залишатися самим собою і робити те,
що можу, для своєї країни. Це і є громадська робота.
Як Ви розцінюєте Зеленського на посаді президента?
Мені поки важко його оцінити.
І всі, з ким я спілкувався і в Європі, і в Україні,
поки не розуміють, чого він хоче і які в нього цілі.
Я бачився з ним двічі. Один раз в аеропорту і вдруге на форумі YES.
Я дивився на нього, і мені було цікаво зрозуміти всередині себе,
щирий він чи прикидається. Для мене це було дуже важливо.
І висновок, якого я дійшов попередньо:
я вважаю, що він щирий всередині, він говорить те, що хоче,
і робить те, що говорить - це головне.
Питання, чи зможе він це зробити, чи дадуть йому це реалізувати
люди, з якими він працює.
І чи захоче він сам це робити, я не знаю.
Ми не знаємо свого майбутнього. Поки я вважаю, що він щирий.
Як вийшло так, що дві такі близькі в минулому країни -
як Росія та Україна, опинилися в такому стані, в якому вони є нині?
Ви повинні розуміти, що це не протистояння двох країн чи навіть двох народів,
це протистояння світоглядів. Одні хочуть жити прогресивно -
українці, хочуть жити, як у Європі, за європейськими стандартами і принципами,
у вільній цивілізованій країні, демократичній.
А те, чому вони протистоять, так званий "рускій мір",
російський режим, путінський режим -
це ті люди, які хочуть жити, як у Радянському Союзі.
Тільки у Радянський Союз повернутися неможливо, бо він вже помер,
тому це апріорі приречена система, цінності, які вони намагаються навязати.
Я просто п'ять років пробув у Росії, п'ять з половиною,
перебував у тому інформаційному просторі,
тому про Росію я зараз знаю більше, ніж про Україну, про Європу.
Тому я можу зараз розуміти їх і дуже добре те, що там відбувається.
Що ви зрозуміли про Росію?
Те, що я сказав, що всі там - керівництво і багато людей -
мріють повернутися у Радянський Союз.
Імперські амбіції ними керують,  навіть простими людьми, у яких немає нічого,
які ведуть стиль життя напівбомжів, грубо кажучи,
але радіють Криму, радіють протистоянню з Америкою,
радіють якимось ракетам,
тобто це ніяк не стосується їхнього життя, яке не покращується.
Ну, вони от радіють, що ми Америці втерли носа,
ми Європі втерли носа, ми он мочимо українців на Донбасі -
як добре, як чудово, які ми молодці!
Отак вони думають, і це жахливо.
Тому що головна проблема нинішньої Росії не те, що там політична система
неправильна чи економіка зайшла в глухий кут,
а те, що дуже сильно деградувало суспільство, дуже сильно.
Не всі, звичайно. Важко оцінювати, але відсотків 80, 65,
значно більше половини. Дуже сильна деградація відбулася,
і я не знаю, що вони будуть з цим робити, тому що тупик розвитку суспільства -
це дуже страшно. Тому що політична система
може змінитися і за день, і за два.
Я пам'ятаю, як розвалився Радянський Союз за три дні,
я пам'ятаю, як скинули Януковича за три місяці.
Путінський режим теж рано чи пізно впаде,
а от свідомість людей змінювати дуже важко, дуже довго.
А  вона зараз, на жаль, перебуває у такому стані - моральний глухий кут.